dwayne haskins the washington
quarterback spotted sunday night
celebrating the vic
the loss to the seattle seahawks at a
strip club
with no masks or other personal
protective equipment that would prevent
him from getting coveted 19
and it all hit the fan yesterday and it
was still kind of vague and unclear
a couple of people reported the
washington football team was aware of it
chris and they were dealing with it and
and then dwayne haskins apologized yeah
right and it was
a clear acceptance of responsibility
possibly not written by him but
nevertheless adopted by him on a twitter
account that he would eventually delete
he may have resurrected it by now who
knows
but look this is
a an issue for the washington football
team because you have a guy who
is blatantly violating the protocols
regardless of where he went it could be
a movie theater
a strip club a nightclub a restaurant
anywhere
if you're doing something that violates
the agreed to protocols between the nfl
and the nflpa about where you can and
can't go and what you can and can't do
that's a problem because you're
potentially bringing the virus to the
building and washington's
in first place in their division this
isn't a team that's out of it out of it
right this is a team that's in it
and for the guy who's had an opportunity
to resurrect his career lately
by virtue of the alex smith injury this
is one of the ultimate unforced errors
chris
ultimate i mean unforced errors and and
really like a lot of different ways too
that's that's where i just don't
understand it i mean one like like you
said
yeah they're in the playoff race okay
that's great
all right two hey obviously it's a
pandemic
i mean come on what are we doing here
you know to go into
any club bar strip club whatever that
type of environment is just
incredibly careless let alone against
nfl protocols
then okay let's take it a step further
there's the pandemic and all that stuff
right
i mean just the look of being
okay in the strip club sunday after a
loss listen i'm with you i mean guys do
do what you do that's fine that's fine
but that's still
not the look that a franchise
quarterback or a guy that wants to be a
franchise quarterback
should be trying to portray to the
football team in washington
or any of the other teams in football
that
you know might want his services
depending on what happens after this
year or
going in the next year we don't know
where dwayne has gonna be
so that in itself is just disturbing
you know when you become a franchise
quarterback as you know i mean hey the
guy
he wants to be that guy well you know
then you have to kind of be that guy
off the field not that you have to be
perfect in a boy scout and do those type
of things but
when you're out having a good time after
a loss
and in a lot of ways you can pin that
loss
on you then that's an issue and then it
also just speaks to the bigger picture
issues of dwayne haskins and everything
we've heard over the last two years
about immaturity and all that so yeah
like just
annoyed i'm annoyed by it i want to
publicly apologize for my actions this
past sunday he said on twitter i spoke
with coach rivera yesterday
and took full responsibility for putting
the team at risk it was irresponsible
and immature of me and i accept
responsibility for my action i also want
to apologize for creating distraction
for my team
during our playoff push i will learn and
grow from this and do
what's best for the team moving forward
and i see three ingredients to this
chris
immaturity is one of them intelligence
or lack thereof is the
other and then there's just that notion
of good old-fashioned
entitlement it's not like it used to be
in the nfl pre-2011 when the players
taken to the very top of the draft
had contracts that were so massive and
cap hits so extreme
that they became untouchable that was
one of the reasons why
the veteran players were so quick to
embrace a rookie wage scale that knocked
down what these guys made even in a
roundabout way it hurts the veterans
because
the the higher the rookie salary they
parlay that into their second contract
it pulls the market up for
everyone else and they all potentially
benefit no they were content to just say
we're done with these guys who come in
here these punks who come in here
and no one can talk to them and no one
can get through to them right because
what are you going to do
go ahead cut me i got 60 million
guaranteed
i'll wreak havoc on your salary cap go
ahead and cut me so
i i even though that's not to the same
extent now
there's a certain element of that with
wayne haskins he's got a fully
guaranteed contract for four years
so between intelligence or lack thereof
maturity or lack thereof
and entitlement it's a stew and it
creates this mess
and just as washington was giving him an
opportunity
yeah and maybe maybe building a trade
market
now it all gets set back and it's all on
him and it's a shame
that he doesn't have the awareness to
realize what
just yeah you always assume that
the photos are going to come out being
watched they're going to like yeah
you're everywhere you go
big brother is everywhere and everywhere
all of us it's not the government it's
all of us with these things
so i i'm just stunned and i know that
he's young and i know it's only his
second year but i'd like to think he
would have picked something up
especially this year when they're being
told over and over again where they can
and can't go
well right and you know you you get you
do get
benched and at one point you're not even
dressing for football games
that should be a big like you know
blinking signal to go
man wait something's not right here i
need to fix myself
and the situation and everything that's
involved and then
you know even after that when he was
benched early in the year there was
some other you know immature things that
he did along the way that i know that
that have happened down there in
washington
so you know this was a chance you know
yes he threw the interceptions in the
game against the seattle seahawks we
talked about it monday though there was
a lot of good things he did i actually
liked the way he looked
i thought wow you know him if he does
have to start this week
for for alex smith like washington has a
chance
he he's he's got a good feel for the
game he looked good he made decent
decisions throughout most of the game
other than that you know
second quarter interception but this is
just yeah
reckless like stupid i don't know what
else to say
and you're gonna lose respect in the
locker room and this type of decision
at this moment in december play off push
pandemic strip club after a loss
is like if he becomes a free agent or
anything like that
this moment is gonna go to every other
team's head right away and they're gonna
go
wait he did that did he really do i
really want that guy on my team
i mean that this this sunday what he did
is going to be the first thing anybody
thinks about signing him they're going
to think about that from
all the aspects we've we've already kind
of talked about
especially given the position he plays
yeah he's usually gloss over if you're a
corner or a defensive lineman linebacker
running back whatever you are the guy
of the team you are the leader of the
team you're the guy that needs to be
counted on to show up early stay late
influence teammates to make good
decisions how do you influence anyone to
make good decisions
when you have made such a bad decision
at such a critical time
in a critical season between the playoff
push and the pandemic trying to hold it
together
the nfl in so many ways is that
car that is making its way to the finish
line and there's a wheel that's coming
off and the radiator's
busted and the tailpipe's dragging and
sparks are going everywhere
but it's going to make it and dwayne
haskins is behind the wheel just going
wherever he wants to go with it and it's
amazing
because there are so many stories like
that that we know of and that we don't
know of
i don't know how they've held this thing
together chris yeah for as long as they
have
and i think there's a certain amount of
good old-fashioned
dumb luck that has helped because there
are plenty of
dumb guys who have done dumb things all
year counter to what the nfl is trying
to do
to keep the train on the track yes
yes you're right but i think you know i
think in totality
it's been pretty good by the players and
everybody if they were out and about
and i know not everybody's a you know a
household
you know face and name and all of that
but
you know i think anybody that's one of
the top 10 15 players on their roster if
they were out and about
and in a bar and doing stuff like that
like it would get out
like so i just think we know for the
most part what's going on
and yes this is a stupid instance by
dwayne haskins and we've seen a few
other by a few other teams and players
and all of that but i think for the most
part
i i give the players credit for what
they've done this year
you know i think from my friends i've
talked to and coaches and just a few
friends i know in the league
most locker rooms were all in on hey
let's do the right thing let's get the
hell out of the facility let's go home
really try to do your best to limit you
know interactions with the outside world
and
i i do want to give them credit i do and
and even then when you consider how the
pandemic continues
to rage throughout the country
if i'd have known where it would stand
today with the number of infections and
deaths and the
availability rate at icus and hospitals
throughout the country and most of us
just kind of
maybe we're blind to it because we're at
home all the time and we only have this
prism of
of information and we're selective about
what we listen to and we can only take
so much of it but if we had known how
bad it was going to be we never would
have dreamed that football would have
held it together so it is impressive a
collective effort
yeah that is strong enough to overcome
the periodic stupidity
that we have seen hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports